it was like a thing that would shoot out
the dodge balls and super fast
so for some reason they had cranked this
thing up to like the highest speed but
in the movie you're not going to really
read that
so they put me in front of it they're
like we're going to hit you a few times
you're going to catch it and the first
thing came and it was so
kind of powerful i go guys this is crazy
like no one's going to be able to tell
if the thing's going 80 miles an hour or
60 miles an hour or 40 i said you got to
tone this thing down like this is
dangerous
only to come to find out that the great
justin long
had already been there for an hour
getting hit by this machine at full
speed
multiple times
swingers i like john right away
he was um you know very funny he was
with the improv olympic in chicago
and i was with that same improv company
prior to him uh being there i had
already moved to l.a
so we had a lot of common ground do you
think that we're going to vegas mike
vegas you think we get there by midnight
money we're going to be up 500 by
midnight
vegas baby vegas was funny because john
wrote the script and a lot of the jokes
and funny lines that i had said in real
life were in the movie
so a lot of the expressions and things
that are in the film was stuff that i
used to say just joking around with him
but yeah the character was sort of based
on
inexperience of john did go through a
breakup when he moved to town
and i definitely took him out that was
the neighborhood i hung out and i used
to love to go see those old
big bands and swing bands and all those
places where i lived in that area so
those were the places i would go to a
lot of the ex-punk bands started playing
swing music it was incredible to go see
these 15
piece bands play original swing music
and it's you and me and the bottle makes
three tonight
finish you and me and the bottle makes
three tonight
so i definitely took john to those
neighborhoods and out to those places
and then with girls and stuff it was i
was encouraging to him
about you know dating and this kind of
stuff in a positive way
that stuff was all true but then for a
comedy it's you know over exaggerated
not everything that happens in the movie
was what happened in real life
so there was a lot of you know the
comedic styles of trent the phraseology
the way that he talked was all
you know characters i would slip into at
times when you're joking around or
expressions i would use
there's nothing wrong with letting the
girls know that you're money and that
you want a party
ready to order yeah that stuff was all
stuff that i had actually said so it was
kind of odd in reading it
originally because a lot of the the
jokes and stuff were just stuff that
came from
us hanging out and things that i said
the lost world jurassic park
greenpeace uh which were there women
80 female greenpeace yeah it was a
different experience for sure
i always liked steven's movies uh you
know as a kid so many of them
whether it was e.t or close encounters
or jaws were so impactful
so i remember meeting him and talking
film with him a lot we would have these
meetings and we'd just talk about old
westerns or movies and he was very
generous
he was very engaging with a much younger
person who
was excited about the films but we would
just sit and talk about these things and
hear his perspective so it really was a
lot of fun and then
going to do the movie was a very
different experience as you said
swingers we kind of
shot that thing we didn't have permits
you know we were kind of stealing shots
and then obviously you go to a budget
of a film that kind of is allowing of
everything
[Music]
jeff goldblum was great julianne moore
was great we had a pete possible wait
who i liked very much was in that film
and it was just a different exercise you
know being able to look at something
that was not a dinosaur and pretending
it was was just
you know an exercise in imagination
psycho it was like a warhol painting
almost i had like gus's movies like
drugstore cowboy in private idaho so it
was more about working with him
than it was even doing psycho at that
age i didn't really think about remaking
a movie so much it's like you know
an artist would cover a song and then
another artist would cover a song and
this was a movie that gus
liked so it was really exciting to go
work with him and then once the process
started it was odd because
there was moments when we sort of were
going to do it as a shot for shot
and then there was times when we would
drift where it wasn't exactly that it
was an interesting exercise as an actor
to explore
because there were certain times we were
looking to match
you know what was done and you had to
find your own internal way of getting
there
without it feeling you know like you're
just sort of executing it
and so the exercise of that was really
interesting and
i kind of enjoyed doing it i thought it
was um
just like an interesting and interesting
uh experience to have
old school well i was on the page todd's
a terrific writer and great with comedy
so
the part that was interesting was the
studio didn't know if i could do comedy
because at that point i had done a lot
more having done swingers and then lost
world i just sort of instinctively
gravitated to more kind of
character-based stuff and returned to
paradise or clay pigeons i had been
doing much
kind of more smaller indies but i hadn't
done a lot of mainstream comedy so
i think he maybe had to show them an
interview i did on a talk show or
something to
make them comfortable that i could do
the comedy so that was
that was interesting for me because i
had sort of come from comedy max
can you hear muffet for me we are going
to get so much ass here it's going to be
sick i'm talking like crazy like boy
band-ass
the fun of that character for beanie was
really
you know you you love your friend a lot
so that goes a long way with audiences
and just in general that he's his
heart's in the right place for his
friend
but then you just start to build things
that are specific he's kind of a hustler
who um is ambitious with speaker city
you know trying to build this empire but
it's it's it's you know speaker city
speaker city
which is slashing prices on everything
from beepers to dvd players
give a warm harrison university welcome
to my pal and your favorite mr
snoop dogg he was so encouraging of his
friend
to go and have a relationship he was
sort of excited
for the big parties and to get the stuff
going with the college girls and stuff
as a guy that was at the time was 30
but ultimately you know he really loved
his wife he wasn't going to do anything
to kind of jeopardize that
so i i thought was fun about him was he
had the
support of a friend he liked to have a
good time he was
not completely happy in his marriage but
he was ultimately a guy that valued his
marriage and wanted to try to make it
work
that was one of the best scripts i ever
read that thing changed not as much
as other scripts had it was really well
done and what i liked about
it was in old school and then later in
wedding crashers i'm not the lead so i
get to be a little more
wild and dodgeball the character really
grounds the audience he's kind of a sane
man in an insane world stiller's
character's so specific and all the guys
that go to average joe's gym
are really specific and unique
it's a bad time i could always come back
so i thought that it was important for
the character to kind of have this
personality you know be a likable guy
again
very loyal begrudgingly so to the people
that depended on him not that he was
wanting to be there for them but he just
ultimately couldn't
uh help them he would rather have found
a way to not have these responsibilities
but once he got connected to all the
guys at the gym he couldn't not be there
for them and so
i think for peter lafleur he's kind of
the eyes of the audience you're meeting
all these interesting people at the
dodgeball gym you're coming in conflict
with stiller
and so he's sort of the grounded
character on a journey that's
the world is much more kind of bizarre
than than he is
people have different translations
through different things and that's a
special bond that you have with the
with your mail-order wife i think that's
nice thank you it's fine i remember
showing up uh and they had the rosten
who was the director
i think played division three sports and
a lot of times
the case will be with guys that kind of
played sports later but not like
big time they overly want to do stuff
like
for him it was so important to overly
throw the ball and overly do this
there was a scene where they had this
kind of like i guess you would use it
for
for baseballs it was like a thing that
would shoot out the dodgeballs and super
fast
so for some reason they had cranked this
thing up to like the highest speed but
in the movie you're not going to really
read that
so they put me in front of it they're
like we're going to hit you a few times
you're going to catch it and the first
thing came and it was so
kind of powerful i go guys this is crazy
like no one's going to be able to tell
if the thing's going 80 miles an hour or
60 miles an hour or 40 i said you got to
tone this thing down like this is
dangerous
only to come to find out that the great
justin long
had already been there for an hour
getting hit by this machine at full
speed
multiple times so he definitely had a
strong commitment to
going through the pain of the of the
experience
wedding crashers that screenplay changed
quite a bit
um including the structure the original
version i think was both
owen and my character crossing the
marriage of uh
of bradley cooper and rachel mcadams it
wasn't me and isla getting married and
then him coming to us so
we had a really good idea owen's very
funny and a good writer
and david's terrific so we really just
kind of rebuilt it we it was an
interesting time like it started with
old school where we were able to do
these more hard r comedies and be left
alone no one was telling us you can't
say that
we were kind of young kids trying to
make each other laugh
and in doing so we're able to create
something that felt authentic and
crashes was the same thing we were
really left alone to kind of build these
characters create these flawed guys
have those three weeks to sort of pitch
ideas write scenes
you know like the me wanting to keep the
painting when i leave that was owen's
idea
he was like it'd be so funny after that
guy drew the painting that you it means
something to you now that you want to
take it with you so
we really use that time to kind of build
the scenes out
play with the structure of the movie and
i think it translates you know having
that time when we got into those scenes
swingers was similar because we
rehearsed that movie so much trying to
get it made
so i think having that time to really
dive in and have a little bit of
ownership over the lines and the
dialogue
i'm looking all over for you i gotta get
out of here i got a stage five klinger
uh i need more time
did you hear what i just said to you
stage five virgin klinger
let's go i'm gonna start the car i'm
serious let's go
i think that really translated uh in the
screen was a lot of fun was a
lot of work but it was really enjoyable
the breakup
you know it was my idea of the breakup
and what it was is i was being sent a
lot of rom-coms i had never done one
prior to it and i thought gosh
you know it's always kind of the same
motor these guys whatever then the guy
goes and apologizes and the girl takes
him back
and they end up happily ever after and
so i thought well how about two people
that really love each other
but they just don't have the skills yet
either of them
to make the relationship work i had
found in my own life that sometimes you
could really like someone but
neither you are either ready to be in
something more serious or you just don't
have the maturity or the skills to
handle situations
and you can end up kind of ruining the
relationship don't tell me what i
am or aren't not doing what you are not
not doing don't just learn some english
once you ruin it it's hard to go back
like once someone feels
like the other person has broken trust
or
let them down hurt their feelings even
though
you may still like them you just can't
go back to that and you learn your
lessons from that experience and
hopefully you don't repeat the same
mistakes in the next relationship so
i had played a lot of characters at the
time that were kind of fun
but i really was driving to have this
film where the guy wasn't confident or
mature enough to address things well but
you could tell his heart was in the
right place
and then the girl would be a little
gamey she wasn't totally mature either
it's sort of both of their faults she's
manipulating the situation more than
than one should they're both somewhat
immature and that you would build to
this moment that when the guy
finally got to that revelation that he
was able to go to her
hat in hand which you had seen so many
times
that the girl had gotten to a place
where it was burnt out he had let her
down so many times
that she just wasn't able to reciprocate
in a way
and that the guy in the moment would
then kind of have this
this wisdom and dignity to be accepting
of that it was awkward there was another
guy outside and he sort of
really authentically you could tell he
moved past his immaturities because
he handled that moment so gracious and
then the tragedy at the end of the movie
in a way
was here were these two people who both
kind of liked each other but they both
handled it
really terribly and then obviously with
the ending when they sort of see each
other to realize
you know you're better off at the other
side of it it never feels like it when
you go through a breakup like that
but ultimately having gone through those
experiences or sometimes the things that
put you in a better place
to both pick someone who's in a better
place for where you're at and also have
better skills not to ruin a relationship
and then the question for people was
well did it work out between those two
or not which
you know is up to everyone to decide i
think if they met each other at the
stage they were at once they went
through the experience they probably
would have worked out
and and that was really the the point
was that they both had come out of it
even though it was painful
more equipped for relationships than
when the movie started and that had a
big table scene that took a lot of days
to film as well
where john michael higgins who's
terrific with john michael higgins gets
gets up and sings in my face owner of a
lonely heart you're every step you take
you and you and that's the only way
true detective you know having done
swingers and
roles like that the characters are very
confident and they're very articulate
and you know able to move with a lot of
self value
and then with frank what i found in that
what i did was in the early stages of
the piece he's trying to go
corporate he's trying to go legitimate
and he's using big words and stuff but i
felt that the character didn't really
have a grasp on it that he was over his
skis
and so i really tried to you know as the
character come off
confident and pro proficient but
actually underneath it
to trying to be something he wasn't so
it was interesting to start that piece
where you have this guy
who is not really
self-assured although he's this kind of
foreboding character
there's a rage and an anger in him you
see a lot of
you know hurt in him there's a little
kid in there that doesn't feel
loved and he's sort of you find him in a
moment where
he's trying really hard but he just does
he has a lot of self-doubt and things
are slipping away from him
and then as the piece progresses he
starts to become far more
assured and confident he kind of reverts
back to what he was trying to escape he
knows who he is when he's someone who's
going to be
more violent or this is the way i handle
things now i understand this and this is
probably on
where i always saw my life going he's
going to protect the one thing he loves
but he's prepared at that point to face
to face his ends that's all rich
well you know i always put a lot of
research even in the earlier movies with
studying
you know either people or learning about
different experiences for hacksaw ridge
i had gone
i never did a lot of press for it but i
had gone a lot starting with dodgeball
taking movies overseas to the troops i
had gone to iraq and afghanistan
and was able to show the movies which
was funny i thought gosh these guys
these
guys and girls are stuck over here in
this terrible situation
well maybe these movies are funny maybe
i can go take dodgeball over and show it
to the
the troops i didn't realize when i got
there that a lot of them had copies of
the movie for me this
to sign even though the movie was just
coming out in america
because they had there was pirated
versions that would get sold overseas
that were like you know have someone's
head
in the video while they were watching
the movie i just went into a very kind
of deep dive about
what was it like the sergeants and the
drill sergeants and
the preparation when it's actually
wartime and how these things kind of
play out and then
sort of tried to build out a specific
character in this situation where you're
dealing with someone
you know like desmond who you can tell
us you know you don't even know if he's
telling the truth at first is this guy
even honest is he presenting what's real
and then having the concern for the
group at that time as your highest
demand which is these kids are going
over to fight
and kill people they got to stay alive
and this may be a hard on this
individual but we really need to do
what's best for the unit to live
and this guy's not going to be an asset
to anybody he's going to get someone
killed and then
which was true to real life being swayed
by this person's
faith his belief realizing he really
does have a conviction
in what he's doing and to sort of be won
over by this kid and ultimately the
journey that
desmond dawes went on was so incredible
i never heard the story
so it was really kind of building out
you know and then finding your own
individual personality with that with
how you would kind of approach it and
and um put yourself in those
circumstances
draw on cell block 99 rosalie was such a
great writer
and i had liked bone tomahawk quite a
bit and bradley
i think being a little bit different
than the other character but jim was a
guy who kind of
knew who he was didn't feel a need to
talk a lot you know wanted nice things
in life
and one of them being a relationship
with this woman that he loves i had kind
of a specific
pass for him that had a lot of violence
and stuff in it so
that's actually the scene when reading
the script that most moved me
because i found it surprising and also
authentic that
you discover that the girlfriend is
cheating or your wife as it would be
and you're filled with rage and hurt and
so he tells her to go inside
he he he obviously feels like he can't
control his emotions but he has enough
wherewithal
i think he's suggesting in some way that
you need to get away from me because i'm
not fully in control
of how i'm feeling so she leaves him
he's unable to process what he's feeling
so he takes it out on a car which i
think a moment people have been mad
maybe they
throw something across the room but i
think his commitment to really
methodically destroying the car
shows a real ocean of hurt and rage
and then it was the scene afterwards
that i quite liked when you come to find
out that there was a miscarriage
and the marriage going bad he doesn't
blame all of the infidelity on her even
though she's the one that has
you know acted out in this way he's able
to hear her and recognize
that some of the choices he's been
making have not been up to par and what
i loved was that after having this very
you know honest conversation with each
other he's clearly
someone who's both angry and very hurt
over this they decide to become closer
and i really believe
that i really bought in that
conversation through the
the way that things were discussed that
those two people did become closer that
they i could say wow this is interesting
one could see
the infidelity and the trust being
broken as something that would divide
them
but in this case i'm really believing
that they're both being able to be
vulnerable and it brought them closer
together and i think that's kind of
zoller
in his writings he he doesn't lay out
set up in obvious ways where they go now
i'm rooting for this character
i think the characters surprise you the
stories surprise you
and they feel sort of um authentic
but not not kind of formulaic
you're gonna stop now i'm fortunate in
that i wrestled
uh in high school and junior high and
then i boxed a little bit just really
you know staying in shape but i had done
it younger than i did it older just
for exercise so i had a good foundation
but it was demanding i loved the
artistry of zoller and his commitment he
really wanted to make
these shots live in these shots and have
it be us so it was a bit like
choreographing a dance like these are
not
we're not going to be able to hide and
just land a punch and have it work you
had to really be
consistent with the sequence that might
be 15
20 moves and there was really not a lot
of room for error so
we sort of rehearsed it the coordinator
was great zoller is terrific we would
really
practice these sequences but then
ultimately when you get there on the day
you kind of have to go for it
you can't overthink it so you want to
keep everybody safe
and at the same time you want to have
the right emotion going on
to make the the sequence be as grounded
and believable as possible and it's kind
of a weird balancing act because
you can't really be too in your head so
there was a couple times i got caught or
someone else did not not very often but
we really made the decision to really go
for it and be
err on the side of kind of being a
little bit more physical and aggressive
and i think for the film it really works
freaky yeah i like chris landon a lot
he's really good in this genre of kind
of horror with comedy which is not an
easy thing to do so the butcher was fun
i just try to make him specific
malicious you know kind of a pleasure
and hurting people
enjoying it quiet and then for millie it
was really just kind of you know
studying girls of that age and then
building a character that was unique and
specific here's a girl with a turbulent
home life and i think it's really
relatable for all kids that age you're
caught between what your parents think
your life should be and what they want
for you
and sort of being able to say this is
what i want and both knowing what that
is and being able to give voice to it
and she's someone i think we all can
relate to she doesn't feel confident in
school
she's got a crush on someone who she
doesn't believe would reciprocate
she's got a really nice group of friends
and some close
relationships but she's sort of at that
coming of age moment where she's
learning to own her own voice and to
have some belief in herself and again
for comedy you're kind of
i try to keep the character grounded
with with real
stakes but then in certain you know the
over commitment to the absurd
is sort of where the comedy comes from
at times the um
and that's really landon and the writing
and the situations that he would put us
in